let's get into it Michael my hearty do
you like the call of duty yeah yeah used
too much more what was your watch
favorite call duty game first modern
warfare or call duty to god for all day
to a lot of people I called do too yeah
was that did you play it on console yeah
that was my first xbox 360 game I think
that's why a lot of people liked it it
was I worked at a gamestop back there
and when we were selling 360s everyone
was getting caught to yes like one of
the best like new first but i think was
because everyone was waiting for halo 3
or something yeah cuz it was called duty
to like Madden 06 or something and then
um perfect dark zero yeah didn't really
watch it Gotham Racing man in that
everyone wanted that I didn't play that
and I want about yourself your mobile
battlefield fam but you like call it
called you I did I started I went up
through I just played like modern
warfare 2 and at that point I was like
this series is hit its pinnacle I don't
know if I really need to continue from
here but I know a lot of people love the
black op series i played the single
player and loved it I'm at a point now
where I actually will play call of duty
for the single player and I played
battlefield for the multiplayer
interesting because I feel like I've
kind of done it um but I gotta say that
was the first game where I remember you
know modern warfare was the game that
kicked a whole generation out of the
World War two yes genre totally like
that is what put a fork in world war two
and it's funny because I feel like we're
coming back around again we're now
people are sick of the modern warfare
and we're like coming back to people
asking for a World War two again for
sure I think and people would not have
been surprised if this or I guess the
battlefield reveal will be on thursday
if if either of them went towards world
war two again we'll talk about it later
on the show but yeah interesting to see
that the news has come out that a call
of duty infinite warfare is going to
double down on its space levels and is
straight up a game set in space whisk
you know asteroid mining and off world
development stuff like that it had a
sick Major Tom trailer it did as an M&M
so no well they uh yeah I was cut at the
side I was like okay fair enough you
know good timing you know respect to
David Bowie but then I could have M&M
dude major town got the note no I
thought it was it was a decent trailer
the first half the trailer wasn't super
hot on but the second half was a little
bit better as so let's dive into the the
meat potatoes it is and first of all I
got a quote here
which was given directly to gamespot and
infant a warrant if an infinite warfare
so infinity war god that's gonna be
really we just call that infinite duty I
feel like they mrs. Doody Duty never
stops our duty all the duty jakab
minkoff says the approach that we've
taken with this game the inspiration
don't come from sci-fi or space in any
way the inspiration comes from more
stories this is call of duty we are
talking about warfare and this in this
case infinite warfare what we feel is
that classically told narratives can
take the plate can take place in any
settings they are very worried about
saying that this is a sci-fi shooter I
feel like they are worried of losing
their crowd which is like a problem that
Activision have with this series is that
it's almost like too big of a seller to
make take any risks so what do you guys
think about the fact they're going for
the sort of modern warfare future
warfare and there were a future future
warfare the live stream had two very
contradictory tones to it on one hand
they said yes multiplayer is going to
take place on other planets and
potentially on space stations but in
like a sense later they're like oh but
we're not going to change anything
because we don't want to scare off our
crab basically right what they said so
that makes me worried that they're just
going to change the skybox in the level
design and then keep the same gameplay
whereas I would love it if some
developer would like change the formula
first-person shooters and start doing
things like forget flat maps let's do
maps on like a spherical asteroid and
let's do like variable gravity or let's
do just something like that's different
from these flat static maps we've been
getting for the past decade mmm
l'évolution from battlefield it wasn't
really that big of a thing Call of
Duty's had one or two destructible items
in their environment and sometimes
things happen to change routes but like
I would really like one of these
developers to get creative with multi
yeah I mean they dip their toe in the
water with so with the Kevin Spacey born
I was we had that's modern say which one
advanced advanced warfare sorry and then
blops tree as well they sort of had some
of the you know titanfall esque movement
in there but you're right in saying that
like it you know we think about call of
duty 4 modern warfare as this game that
really broke the genre because it like
took another world war 2 but actually
though it had that big thematic shift in
terms of its gameplay it also that's
sort of a really change was that oh it
was the game that like made first of all
a really solid varied mechanically
single-player campaign it wasn't just
having different warfare in different
places it was like different types of
warfare like the ghillie suit stuff and
big massive battles and then sort of
smaller stealthy stuff and then
alongside that they basically invented
the type of multiplayer that we never
playing for ten years so since then
we've had all these tiny little
iterative steps and every once in a
while they take like a bigger little
step or like double down on the zombies
or go towards the future stuff but I
mean Mike at this age is a time for them
to you know Mary the thematic step
they're taking here with some actual
changes to have quality plays yeah one
hundred percent I don't want it to be I
mean the thing that would get me and a
lot of people interested in the series
again is if they like Aaron was saying
it's not just a new paint it's an actual
like functional change they make to the
game like you said like I know they're
talking about 0g combat and they did
have that the beginning of ghosts which
Infinity Ward also did it wasn't the
best game but I thought maybe if they
did more that that would have made them
for an interesting game or at least kind
of you know changeup how we're poaching
this it's not just this stop and pop
shooter right I'd like them to actually
kind of whatever happened back then
because they had a big audience with our
world war two shooters but they took a
chance with modern warfare they you know
like you said they implemented this
multiplayer that's become so pervasive
yeah I would love for them to just say
alright screw it let's try something new
and maybe spark another ten years of
something and for the first four years
that we can be excited again yeah I mean
there's been so much evolution in terms
of first-person games in recent years as
well like the open world thing is
completely changed like far cry changed
the rule book a large like games like
dying lives even just like took what
Mirror's Edge tried to do and then
expanded at in so many interesting ways
call of duty is still the same like
super hyper linear and I don't really
like I'm cut totally with you I enjoy
playing the single-player campaign
Sinise but I almost enjoy them a lot
because they're short like I could not
deal with that for 15 hours but I can
like deal with it for like a weekend and
it's like it's kind of fun and a little
bit entertaining and but even I'm not
like they're never really that the Hulk
really isn't there that it was back in
two thousand and six seven I mean also
you get used to the adrenaline rush of
these games it becomes normal to you and
when modern warfare first came out I was
it was the only game i played where i
was late
shaking like at the end of a round
because there had never been multiplayer
that intense before but then by modern
warfare 2 is a little bit less and then
black ops came around I was like
whatever like I'm already immune to this
level of crack right yeah you know it's
just like and then let's start getting
boring cuz it was like geez I just walk
around a corner and shoot somebody like
i respawned before my old body hits the
floor and then i do it again and again
and again and again and just yeah it
lost the intensity because the intensity
was so consistent yeah and I think it's
what you're saying they need to somehow
bring that level of intensity in a new
way and I don't know like I can't tell
you what that is I when you say space to
me I get excited I wanted battlefront to
be more space and that didn't even have
it right so like to me space is such an
amazing palette for gameplay like you
can have ships you can fight on the
hulls of ships right fight inside ships
you can fight an asteroid else I think
of a games like dead space for instance
I go all the various things they manage
to do with us there's so much you can do
when you just get rid of the ground and
Earth's gravity you know and you have
the future setting but you know I don't
well these guys take the risk yeah they
have their franchise crowd yeah I'm
speaking to that they're sort of having
their cake and eating it because they're
deciding to do a remastered version of
you know what many considered you the
best Call of Duty game certainly in the
past you know the modern era call of
duty 4 modern warfare I suck rocker 7
asking a question a lot of people are
wondering what do you think about the
fact that they're not allowing people to
buy this separately this is only for
people who pre-order and the new game
infinite warfare I think it's telling of
what they think might happen I mean
right I think I think a certain time
after released they will just put it on
PSN or something or xbox live but I'm
expecting this package to come out and I
think modern warfare will hold up and
I'm hoping infinite warfare is better
but I'm curious as to whether people
will like the new game more than the
beguine that gets packaged in with it
could you imagine if they sold it
separately and cod4 sold more yeah I
wouldn't be surprised but it would still
be indicative of where the series has
come since that first really great game
yeah I guess it depends how
salif or as well at the end of that and
yeah final thoughts on that are you guys
excited about the theme sort of stuff
like is it new I mean you were saying
before it is there it yeah its shades of
another game right ya know i said i SAT
33 last year and they were talking about
Blops 3 and how all the movement
mechanics were new and I was kind of
scratching my head like this is
titanfall been like in 10 vols movement
mechanics and then I was watching this
trailer and they're talking about
fighting over colonies and resources and
then those own into space and scratching
my head again going you guys are still
chasing titanfall yeah so I want to see
what titanfall 2 does respawn to me is a
much more exciting studio at this stage
because it because it's Finn's about
actually there that's not just his ghost
giving them ideas like you know that
they showed incredible creativity with
titanfall and I would just love to see
what they can do with that franchise and
if we're talking about space that's
where my head's at right infinite
warfare I'll give it a chance like all
other call of duty games but they have
the constraint of their past and you
hiding fall doesn't so I think titanfall
has more potential wait yeah you're
right signal to success is a
double-edged sword thank you so much
both for talking to bed call of duty
infinite warfare it's got a release date
as well it is coming out i'm gonna guess
it's november 6th or something is it
it's coming out the remember fourth for
playstation 4 xbox one and pc you wonder
if they'll be special neo graphics as
well i guess there have to be actually
on the playstation 4 because that's a
that's a rule now yeah let us know are
you excited for call of duty infinite
warfare put your thoughts in the
comments
No